zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
weltweit ist heute wieder großer klima
streik in mehr als 80 ländern wollen sie
von friday is for future wieder auf die
straße gehen und sie sind es auch schon
zb wie hier in italien in vielen vielen
städten auf der ganzen welt unter
anderem in neapel turin und mailand
fordern sie einen entschlosseneren kampf
gegen die erderwärmung
auch in polens hauptstadt warschau sind
vor allem junge menschen auf den straßen
und kritisieren einen zu laschen
klimaschutz durch ihre regierung und
ähnliche bilder und gleiche forderungen
gibt es auch im indischen neu delhi
und in deutschland in mehr als 400
städten und das zwei tage vor der
bundestagswahl ganz besonders blicken
wir natürlich nach berlin mehr als
20.000 teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
werden dort erwartet und eine von ihnen
ist greta thunberg und wir werden gleich
ihre rede live übertragen und sie auch
hier live im interview in der sendung
haben schreibt eure fragen an sie sehr
gerne wie immer wie gewohnt in die
kommentare oder an die eingeblendete und
bekannte e mail adresse zdf zdf heute -
live at
zdf.de
wir blicken nach berlin wo die demo seit
12 uhr los gelaufen ist los gegangen ist
vor ort ist unser reporter carsten
behrendt mittendrin carsten das ist der
achte weltweite klima streik und auch du
warst schon öfter mit dabei ist dieser
dann aber jetzt zwei tage vor der
bundestagswahl schon irgendwie was
besonderes merkt man dass auch in der
stimmung
christina man merkt schon dass das thema
hier großes werden wenn man mit den
organisatoren gesprochen in die seit der
termin bewusst gewählt ist und es ist
der weltweite abstimmung und das war das
schon gesagt ja das in den gruppen halt
gesagt von deutschland hat eine
besondere bedeutung also machen wir
diesen streik geben auch zwei tage vor
der wahl und dieser neubauer die viele
jacken aus der bewegung die hat vorab
gesagt dieser bundestagswahlkampf sei
aus ihrer sicht wirklichkeit befreit und
deswegen sei es halt wichtig heute
nochmal eine botschaft zu senden auch
von den jüngeren menschen der die ganze
bewegung auch in gang gebracht haben dem
noch nicht wählen können
wir hören es ist schon sehr laut
vielleicht wir sehen auch es sind viele
da vielleicht kann mir noch ein bisschen
und mehr ja auch gerade noch so höre
ich rede auch lauter ich vielleicht
können wir auch ein bisschen mehr noch
sehen wer denn da heute angekommen ist
wen hast du denn so getroffen sind es
eher jüngere leute sind es ältere leute
ist es
generationenübergreifend sind es viele
schüler wer ist denn alles da
ja es ist wirklich sehr sehr viele
menschen sehr unterschiedliche da das
ist auch was wir in den letzten jahren
auch letzten jahren ist eine junge
bewegung bei den la clippers streiks
auch beobachtet haben dass viele
familien komplett kommen dass eltern mit
ihren kleinen kindern da sind wirklich
aber auch viele schüler aller
altersgruppen daneben auch studentinnen
studenten wissenschaftler sind daher
sehr stark auch aktiv was ist es schon
eine bewegung die sehr breit ist und es
gab ja auch redebeiträge von einer oma
future die hat gesagt hat mir eure
zukunft so wichtig und deswegen möchte
ich hier auf der bühne stehen und dieses
zeichen setzen und mehr noch hängen
geblieben einen ein sehr junger
teilnehmer der auf der bühne stand und
sagte ich bin jetzt zehn jahre alt wenn
ich in acht jahren wählen darf dann ist
das klima budget das co2 bc weitgehend
aufgebraucht
und dann ist es eigentlich schon zu spät
und erbittet halt dann die ältere
generation doch jetzt für seine zukunft
zu werden also schon sehr sehr politisch
und ich habe jetzt auch ein paar von den
menschen die hier sind uns rausgesucht
damit wir mal deren stimmen hören und
nicht nur nicht nur davon erzähle hier
hinten zum beispiel ist die angst aus
berlin
du bist 13 jahre alt warum bist du denn
heute gekommen mit der schulklasse nein
ich bin mit meiner mutter da und wir
sind heute hier weil wir angst haben
noch durch die erwärmung noch weitere
probleme auf uns zukommen und die
regierung die neue jetzt endlich mal
richtig hat zu durchstreifen sollte okay
was du denn schon mal bei so einer demo
das ist jetzt das erste mal nein ich bin
schon zum dritten mal hier und es hat
mir jedes mal sehr viel spaß gemacht
neben ihr steht eine mutter die du
gerade schon angesprochen hast maria
funk sie sind mit der tochter und
zusammengekommen wer hat er die
initiative gegeben habe dass küchentisch
entstanden also das ist jetzt nicht das
ich speziell die werke gehen dahin und
ihr müssten in sein handy kindern sagen
einmal sehr bereitwillig mit gekommen
weil das oft thematisiert wird bei uns
und warum ist es so wichtig jetzt gerade
zwei tage vor der wahl oder spielt es
für sie eine rolle gerade heute hier zu
sein ja also ich glaube dass einfach in
den letzten jahren die bundesregierung
nichts unternommen hat um die
vereinbarung vom pariser klimaabkommen
wirklich zu erreichen
und ich finde auch nicht dass die
wahlprogramme aktuell so aussichtsreich
sind dass man annehmen könnte dass das
erreicht wird ok vielen dank dennoch
viel spaß hier auf der demo es gibt ja
noch ordentlich programm und auch die
rede von greta bist du deswegen auch
jährigen geräte tun bleibt ja ja
gut wir gehen mal hier noch ein kleines
stück weiter denn hier noch vielen dank
eine sehr bunten eine sehr bunte gruppe
die drei hier da blüht auf dem kopf das
sind ich muss ganz auf meinen schlauen
später konnten sony war claire und
vanessa
also lieber was hat es denn mit eurem
kopfschmuck auf sich an die maske auch
ich halt ein bisschen abstand ja
klar ist eine wundervolle künstlerin und
klimaaktivisten wir wollen mit kunst
zeigen über emotionen wie schön unsere
natur ist wie schön unsere umwelt ist
und zeigen ja wofür wir kämpfen wollen
für diese schönheit und auch
gleichzeitig darauf aufmerksam machen
wie viel von diesen harten auch schon
längst ausgestorben sind die wir niemals
zu gesicht wieder zu gesicht bekommen
werden
du hast mir erzählt du kommst aus den
usa aus kalifornien lebt seit sieben
jahren in berlin ist das eine weltweite
geschichte deine freunde bekannten den
usa weißt du von den ob die auch heute
auf die straße gehen oder reden wir
beiden weitgehend deutsches phänomen
globale problem und meine freundin in
den usa sie streiken auch heute klar du
hattest davor gesagt du hast angst ob du
wirklich auf deutsche antworten kannst
das machst du warst super die botschaft
aber hier auch an die deutsche politik
was ist dir wichtig denn du lebst du ja
auch an dem du darfst ja aber nicht
wählen ja stimmt ich dachte ich wenden
aber ich würde trotzdem mein botschaft
hier bringen dass wir mussten die natur
schützen und wir sind auch teil und die
natur und ja das ist eine wie gesagt ein
globales botschaft und
einige hatten ja gesagt diese bewegung
sei es schon auch durch corona so gut
wie tot es tut sich nicht mehr so super
viel jetzt wie wir es heute dieses
gefühl mit so vielen menschen zu sein
unbeschreiblich wir haben eben schon
gesagt ich glaube wir waren alle drei
noch nie in einer art menge denn so
einer großen menge ja derzeit krone oder
generell noch die ich war noch nie in so
heißt das ich bislang auch nicht großen
thema klimaschutz engagiert bedacht noch
das schon aber ich habe noch nie diese
ja diese klassischen gehabt ja ja und
wie wirkt das herz ist kraftvolles
signal oder eher beängstigend wenn man
es nicht mehr gewohnt dass mit dem
ganzen corona
ich finde es sehr kraftvoll
zu sehen wie viele menschen hier gerade
zusammen gekommen sind für veränderung
für systematischen bande und dass wir
alle hoffentlich aufpassen mit maske und
abstand aber ich auch gerade ich merke
schon ja nein aber es ist ein sehr
ermutigendes gefühl
vielen dank an euch drei und ihren
bunten masken super super gebastelt
erklärt christina
clasen ändert hat sehr sehr sehr sehr
eindrucksvoll danke an dich und deine
gesprächsgäste
und carsten wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter
der sekretär wird sprechen wir haben
auch gerade schon gehört aber viele sind
auch gekommen um sie einmal zu sehen und
zu erleben seit 12 uhr stimmt es geht
die demo schon was passiert jetzt als
nächstes ja
also es ist ja ein großes bühnenprogramm
was hier läuft es gab auch schon
musikalische auftritte klose zum
beispiel wird noch auftreten ich habe
katja riemann gesehen hinter der bühne
also auch schauspieler die hier sind und
um 14 uhr 30 erwarten wir die rede
konkrete thörnberg auf die sich wirklich
hier viele freuen und auch froh sind
dass sie hier vor der bundestagswahl
daneben noch einmal die unterstützung
hier in berlin von ihr haben wir haben
gesehen im internet auf twitter zum
beispiel der kanzlerkandidat der spd
olaf scholz hat getwittert dass er sehr
dankbar ist für die bewegung dass sie
auch heute wieder demonstriert da leben
wir dieses aufspringen auf diesen
klimazug von olaf scholz von einem
kandidaten im netz erleben wir das auch
vor ort sind da auch politikerinnen und
politiker die versuchen da heute noch
mal diese bühne für sich zu nutzen als
wahlkampf
also ich habe in den ganzen mengen hat
noch keine prominenten politiker köpfe
gesehen auch niemanden auf der bühne es
gab die umweltministerin svenja schulze
die hat heute morgen noch gesagt hat in
einem zeitungsinterview diese gruppen
haben schon mehr erreicht als sie
vielleicht selber glauben weil eben das
thema klima im wahlkampf so weit oben
steht aber kurdenpolitiker haben wir
hier noch nicht gesichtet dann vielen
dank für den moment carsten behrendt wir
sind live wieder in berlin wenden die
rede von kreta thunberg beginnt
dankeschön carsten dass du für uns vor
ort warst und um es dazu zu sagen die
falle ist für future bewegung hat sich
auch schon sehr davon distanziert
vereinnahmt zu werden und hat übrigens
auch olaf scholz geantwortet dass sie
auch gegen seine politik demonstriert
also da werden klare trennlinie gezogen
zwischen schweiger ist for future und
der politik aber natürlich ist es zwei
tage vor der wahl eine große frage wie
gehen die parteien auch mit dem
klimaschutz in ihren programmen um und
welche impulse können von dieser demo
heute ausgehen und darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit professor harald lesch in
münchen bekannter
wissenschaftsjournalist und jetzt hier
bei uns in der sendung grüße sie herr
professor lesch und außerdem mit dabei
professor karen pittel seit 2010
direktorin des zentrums für energie
klima und ressourcen des ifo instituts
in münchen frau professor titel wenn sie
gerade die dame mit dem glühenden
kopfschmuck gehört und gesehen haben die
hat sehr viel positiven spirit
mitgebracht und sehr viel gute energie
die sie dort gespürt hat was glauben sie
wie viel davon werden die parteien für
sich nutzen und welche signale gehen von
dieser demonstration heute vor der
bundestagswahl aus
der zeitpunkt ist natürlich ideal kurz
vor der wahl das muss man sagen aber ich
würde mir wünschen es gäbe kurz nach der
wahl wenn die koalitionsverhandlungen
laufen tatsächlich auch noch mal so eine
demonstration in den wahlprogrammen der
parteien steht ja einiges drin wenn man
es kumuliert den einzelnen programmen
sehr unterschiedliche schwerpunkte aber
muss im prinzip alles zusammenschmeißen
damit man glaube ich eine chance hat
überhaupt die klimaziele die deutschland
sich gesetzt hat zu erreichen also
insofern
ich hoffe sehr dass diese positive
stimmung diese aufbruchstimmung auch mit
in die koalitionsverhandlungen reingeht
aber ich denke also das ist meine
grundlegende hoffnung dass wir das
tatsächlich auch erleben werden weil
kurz vor der wahl stand jetzt alles
still da hat sich nicht mehr viel bewegt
das ist nicht groß überraschend aber
nach der wahl wissen die parteien was im
neuen klimaschutzgesetz steht was das
bundesverfassungsgericht geurteilt hat
was die eu macht und da muss einfach
sehr viel passieren das werden wir die
ziele nicht erreichen
herr professor lesch einen kommentar
möchte ich gleich aufgreifen von detlef
pape über facebook kids macht weiter so
ohne euch würde man heute nicht so über
klimaschutz und umweltschutz reden wie
heute ihr habt vielen ins gewissen
geredet und zum nachdenken geführt danke
sehen sie das genauso
ja also ohne zweifel hat freilich
verfügt unglaublich viel bewegt weil die
aufmerksamkeit die achtsamkeit um mal
dieses neudeutsche wort hierzu verwenden
die ist viel viel größer geworden und
man muss einfach sehen dass wenn kinder
auf die straße gehen kinder und
jugendliche auf die straße gehen dann
ist das eine unglaubliche moralische
keule ob man will oder nicht man kann
sich dem nicht entziehen dass also hier
unsere jüngsten an uns erwachsene
appelliert endlich das richtige ihr
wisst schon lange was das richtige ist
und die empfangs die leidenschaft mit
der die kids das machen ist einfach
großartig und das beschämt ja auch viele
offizielle es bestimmt auch viele
offizielle institutionen dass sie über
all die jahrzehnte eigentlich nicht das
gebracht haben was sie schon längst
hätten bringen sollen denn ich finde
schon interessant dass ausgerechnet
unsere kinder und jugendliche auf einmal
in die gesellschaft hinein schreien
erfolgt der wissenschaft und daran sieht
man natürlich was für eine große lücke
daraus ist zwischen dem handeln und dem
was also zwischen dem was sein soll und
dem was tatsächlich passiert das was
sein soll hat falles verfügte sehr klar
formuliert und zwar schäden fasst die
forderung von files for future zusammen
das ziel von price for future die
umsetzung des pariser klimaabkommens
also die begrenzung der globalen
erderwärmung auf 1,5 grad außerdem
klimaneutralität bis 2035 kohleausstieg
bis 2030 und 100 prozent erneuerbare
energieversorgung bis 2035 die
treibhausgasemissionen sollen so schnell
wie möglich stark reduziert werden
deswegen fordern die klimaaktivisten
folgende maßnahmen sofort keine
subventionen mehr für fossile
energieträger ein viertel der kohlekraft
abschalten eine co2 steuer auf alle
treibhausgasemissionen der preis für den
ausstoß von treibhausgasen soll so hoch
sein wie die kosten die dadurch
künftigen generationen entstehen also
180 euro pro tonne co2
laser neubauer von der s p future
fordert einen radikaleren und
konsequenteren klimaschutz von einer
neuen bundesregierung in dem dann das am
ende umgesetzt werden kann was in diesen
forderungen die wir gerade gesehen
enthalten ist wie realistisch ist das
wie machbar ist das
gute frage fast ehrlich gesagt nächste
frage also ich würde mal sagen dass der
gute wille in der politik durchaus
vorhanden ist das aber in einer so durch
verwalteten gesellschaft wie unserer
doch sehr sehr viele hürden zu
überwinden sind um endlich das zu tun
was dringend notwendig ist nämlich zb
die erneuerbaren energien wirklich
massiv auszubauen da gab es ja in den
letzten jahren den letzten fünf sechs
jahren ganz verschiedene hemmschuhe die
es zb geschafft haben das viel zu wenig
windräder gebaut werden dass viel zu
wenig photovoltaik aufgebaut wird das
heißt alles das was wir hätten tun
können ohne großen aufwand haben wir
nicht getan weil verwaltungsvorschriften
genehmigungsverfahren und dergleichen
mehr das ganze so gestoppt haben dass
wir heute zum beispiel was der ausbau
der windkraft betrifft fast auf den
nullpunkt angelangt sind und die
forderungen die sind völlig korrekt und
man muss allerdings auch sehen eben das
tatsächlich hinter der politik ja ein
großer verwaltungsapparat steht der
entscheidet letztlich darüber ob die
energiewende ein volk wird oder nicht
die politik kann ziele formulieren noch
so viel sie will wenn dann in der
praktischen umsetzung einfach viel zu
viele hindernisse da sind dann passiert
da nichts das heißt es kann sein dass
obwohl der politische apparat in
deutschland ganz klare vorgaben macht
letzten endes sehr sehr viel in
verwaltungs- hand in der umsetzung
nachher so schwierig und soja so so
gehemmt passiert dass letzten endes die
ziele nicht erreicht werden selbst dann
wenn alles wollen haben wir uns
inzwischen glaube ich so durch verwaltet
dass wir da wirklich
fassen fast in den in den in dem wald
von von vorschriften hinein schlagen
müssen und eine wichtige für eine der
wichtigsten forderungen finde ich ist
die abschaffung von subventionen denn
ich weiß dass meine kollegin karen
pittel gleich mit dem geld kommen wird
und in den subventionen steckt ja
unglaublich viel geld also wenn ich mich
recht erinnere gab es gibt es im katalog
von dem bundesamt für umwelt und da gibt
es den katalog über umweltschädliche
subventionen das sind von 50 milliarden
die rede das heißt wir reden über einen
großen topf von geld den wir ausgeben
ausdrücklich für umweltschädliche
subventionen und daran sieht man einfach
da ist noch viel zu tun und vor neubau
hat natürlich recht radikale änderung
ist notwendig die frage ist nur ob
unsere gesellschaft und auch die art und
weise wie wir die wir verwaltet und wie
wir zusammenleben
ob das einfach dementsprechend kann oder
ob da noch ganz andere veränderungen
notwendig sind frau titel ich weiß die
diskutieren nicht zum ersten mal sie
sitzen zusammen im bayrischen klimarat
sie haben auch schon für terrex über die
co2 steuer diskutiert deshalb weiß ich
dass sie durchaus unterschiedliche
meinungen sind und würde gerne aber
bevor sie in die diskussion gehen noch
mal gucken wie die parteien sich denn
vorstellen mit dem klimawandel umzugehen
auch das haben wir nochmal
zusammengefasst die afc ist als einzige
partei gegen das pariser klimaabkommen
und den sogenannten green deal der eu
teil dieser maßnahmenpakete die
begrenzung der erderwärmung auf deutlich
unter 2 grad und klimaneutralität bis
die afg lehnt dieses ziel ab die fdp
möchte deutschland bis 2050 klimaneutral
machen cdu csu und spd bis 2045 so steht
es auch im aktuellen
klimaschutzgesetz die grünen teil
spätestens 2041 an die linke
2035 auch bei den energiequellen gibt es
differenzen die afg lehnt den bereits
beschlossenen kohleausstieg bis 2038 ab
die fdp weist darauf hin dass der
ausstieg mit enormen herausforderungen
verbunden sei spd und cdu csu bekennen
sich zum vereinbarten ausstieg die
grünen und die linke wollen ihn schon
bis 2030
[Musik]
solaranlagen auf allen geeigneten
dächern fordern die grünen spd und die
linke die cdu möchte die technologie
ebenfalls fördern die fdp verweist auf
die bedeutung solcher anlagen allein die
afg warnt vor nachteilen der
solaranlagen und sie möchte auch
standorte für windkraftanlagen stark
begrenzen alle anderen parteien wollen
in windenergie investieren
grüne und linke wollen ab 2030 keine
neuwagen mit verbrennungsmotor mehr
zulassen spd und cdu/csu erwähnen kein
konkretes datum
fdp und fw lehnen so einen
zulassungsstopp ab
tja so viele unterschiedliche positionen
der dickkopf schreibt die wahrnehmung in
der bevölkerung ist sobald man klima
files for future hört verbindet man dies
direkt mit den grünen beziehungsweise
man denkt direkt an die grünen dass dem
jetzt nicht unbedingt so sein muss sehen
wir wenn wir in die programme gucken
fast alle parteien haben den klimaschutz
mehr oder minder für sich entdeckt frau
professor titel sehen sie da eher
gemeinsamkeiten oder differenzen wir
wissen es wird mindestens eine zwei oder
eher dreier koalition geben am sonntag
je nachdem wie die ergebnisse sind aber
da werden viele kompromisse geschlossen
werden müssen sehen sie da große
baustellen oder viele gemeinsamkeiten
bei den zielen sehe ich eigentlich schon
eine menge gemeinsamkeiten wenn man
jetzt immer abschied von den genauen
zeitpunkt des ausstiegs quasi also der
klimaneutralität und dem genauen zeit
hat sich schon viele gemeinsamkeiten
aber wie man die emissionen runterbringt
da sind sich die parteien durchaus
uneins das haben wir gerade eben ein
bisschen gesehen einer seite vielleicht
jetzt mal die fdp auf der anderen seite
die grünen die einen die eigentlich
alles versuchen über den co2 preis zu
erreichen die anderen die gegen co2
preis zwar auch erwähnen aber eben nicht
so eine rolle zuweisen zu den 180 euro
vielleicht nur ganz kurz dazu gesagt ist
insofern ganz interessant das ist ja ein
riesen ausschreitungen gab als die
grünen vorgeschlagen haben im prinzip
den anstieg des deutschen co2 preise um
drei jahre vorzuziehen also auf 60 euro
zu erhöhen drei jahren wären wir da
sowieso aber die grünen auch selber in
ihrem parteiprogramm quasi um 480 euro
warnen gleichzeitig hat das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium in der
studie festgestellt selbst mit 180 euro
würden wir die alten niedrigeren
klimaziele bis 2030 nicht erreichen also
man sieht schon dass jeder hat ungefähr
bestimmte vorstellungen zum beispiel co2
bepreisung einzusetzen aber die
differenz dazwischen was man denkt was
wirtschaftlich machbar ist was
gesellschaftlich und akzeptanz mäßig
umsetzbar ist und was die parteien sich
trauen das ist doch ganz erheblich herr
löw sehen sie das auch so
in der tat die parteien müssen sich
natürlich immer wieder zur wahl stellen
und die wählerinnen und der wähler sind
jetzt auch nicht unbedingt alle so
radikal wie die klimaaktivisten das
heißt wir haben durchaus das problem
überhaupt mal bevölkerung soweit zu
kriegen dass sie insgesamt darin
mitgehen und alle versuche in den
parteiprogrammen
das zu formulieren das sehen wir ja auch
in den verschiedenen ziel jahren wann
soll denn was geschehen das ist ja für
viele leute entweder ist es noch weit
weg oder aber es ist gar nicht klar was
ist denn damit eigentlich gemeint mit
klimaneutral geht hier nur um den
stromsektor oder wie müssen wir uns
eigentlich vorstellen wenn wir mehr und
mehr bereiche in zukunft mit
elektrischem strom betreiben wollen also
mit strom der aus erneuerbaren kommt wie
groß sind eigentlich die veränderungen
die sich dann auch für unser auge in
unserem land widerspiegeln würden denn
momentan sind wir sehr gewohnt der strom
kommt aus der steckdose kraftwerke sind
irgendwo weit weg aber die zukunft der
erneuerbaren wird unser land massiv
verändern wir werden viel viel mehr mit
energieproduktion mit energiespeicherung
und energieverteilung zu tun haben und
ich glaube dass es für die parteien ganz
schwierig ist da eine vision zu
entwickeln die für die bürgerinnen und
bürger gerade auch kurz vor der wahl
sagen mal einigermaßen attraktiv ist
klingt alles eher wie eine veränderung
die nicht so viele positive seiten hat
und dass eben diese negative erzählung
sich so durchgesetzt hat bei vielen
parteien das macht es natürlich vor der
bundestagswahl für die parteien schwer
dieses thema positiv zu besetzen eine
frage geht an sie von jpegs herr lesch
was wäre der worst case der eintreffen
würde wenn die ganze menschheit nichts
gegen den klimawandel unternehmen würde
wo fange ich denn an ich fange am
nordpol an das eis ist weg das heißt die
erde wird sich am in der arktis sehr
stark erhitzen wir werden der permafrost
wird auftauen das heißt es wird noch
viel mehr treibhaus aktives gas
freigesetzt werden in dem fall methan
der meeresspiegel wird steigen weil die
gletscher nicht nur in der arktis
sondern auch in grönland also auf
festland verschwinden werden also wir
werden meeresspiegelanstieg kriegen es
wird katastrophale folgen für die
bevölkerung auf allen kontinenten haben
die an den küsten lebt wir werden mehr
extreme wetterereignisse bekommen also
alles das was wir jetzt sozusagen schon
mal in einer miniatur version vor und
sehen bei den großen extremwetter
ereignissen den bränden in sibirien den
bränden in british columbia und so
weiter und so weiter alles das wird sich
noch deutlich verschärfen und wird
natürlich die lebenssituation der
menschheit ganz gewaltig beeinträchtigen
bisschen dazu dass eben weite teile
unseres planeten gar nicht mehr
bewohnbar sind da gibt es fürchterliche
szenarien da geht es um number of days
above the threshold also wo so warm ist
dass wir uns nicht mal mehr dagegen
kühlen können und das würde bedeuten
dass weite teile um den äquator auf der
welt nicht mehr bewohnbar sind
das ist genau das wovor geräten bergwand
und wir können sehen dass sie jetzt
gerade in berlin dabei ist auf die bühne
bekommen deshalb freue ich mich darauf
mit ihnen gemeinsam die rede von greta
thunberg zu hören und danach noch einmal
einzuordnen und gebe jetzt ab nach
berlin auf die bühne vor dem deutschen
bundestag und bin gespannt auf die rede
von greta turmberg
hallo
hallo berlin
dankeschön fürs kommen dankeschön fürs
kommen
[Musik]
freut mich unheimlich so viele leute
hier vor mir zu sehen
das ist schon eine weile her dass ich so
viele leute von mir gesehen hab dann
muss ich mich jetzt erst mal einen
moment daran gewöhnen
wir streiken heute in der ganzen welt
insbesondere hier auch in berlin unter
dem rastatter kaputtes system weil genau
das wollen wir tun
das war sehr turbulent das anderthalb
jahre eine zeit wo wir daran erinnert
worden wie verletzlich wir sind wir
wurden auch daran erinnert wie schnell
sich die dinge verändern können wie sich
die dinge von heute auf morgen komplett
ändern können wir haben in einigen
ländern der welt gesehen so wie es ist
wenn man einen lob situation wirklich
als notstand behandelt und alle
bestimmungen und 9 auf einmal ändert
aber während dieser krise hat sich die
klimakrise natürlich nicht
verabschiedete emission von co2 in die
welt war noch nie so hoch in den letzten
drei millionen ja nicht und 2020 war
gemeinsam mit 2016 das heißeste jahr was
je aufgezeichnet wurde und wir haben
extremes wetter festgestellt in der
ganzen welt viele menschen sind diesen
extrem wetter wird den ihn zum opfer
gefallen nicht zuletzt auch hier in
deutschland und wenn es diese pandemie 1
gezeigt hat dann ist es das die
klimakrise noch nie wie eine richtige
notsituation notstand behandelt wird und
wir wissen dass keine politische partei
genug tut bei weitem nicht aber es ist
sogar noch schlimmer selbst das was sie
vorgeben vorzuhaben würde nicht reichen
ohne die vorgaben des klimaabkommens zu
erreichen wenn du uns die
unterschiedlichen klimapolitik der
politischen parteien anschauen und das
vergleichen mit den ipads ec daten dank
der rabiate 1,5 bleiben würden dann
sehen wir das dann riesenglück geplant
nicht eine partei ist sogar in der nähe
einen weg vorzuschlagen der uns in die
nähe der erreichung der klimaziele
bringen würde klar ist wichtig zur wahl
zu gehen aber das reicht nicht wenn die
sicherstellen wollen dass wir eine
sichere
zukunft auf diesem planeten erde haben
dann müssen der aktive bürger sein und
wie heute auch wirklich auf die straße
gehen als aktivist innen und aktive
wir müssten echte klimaaktivisten dass
die besten werden und ich an und wandte
eingeforderte liefen gedenkt und wandel
ist nicht nur möglich ist
erforderlich und wenn genug leute war
diesel einfordern dann wird es auch zur
wandel kommt am wahltag oder auch danach
und deswegen müssen wir so lange kämpfen
bis es dazu kommt die klima kreis ist
ein akku native krise die co2 emission
die wir jetzt ausgeben werden
jahrtausendelang noch da oben bleiben
und es geht um unsere derzeitige und
zukünftige missionen und es geht um auch
die historischen emissionen aber auch
die emission die wir heute noch in die
luft abgeben und auch in der zukunft
deswegen auch das den klimawandel
deutschland ist das viertgrößte land was
die co2 emissionen in der geschichte
angeht 80 millionen menschen nebenher
deutschland ist objektiv einer der
größten klimasünder
aber nicht nur stellen wir unseren
kindern unseren groß unseren enkeln die
zukunft sondern auch denjenigen die
bereits jetzt unter den folgen
des klimawandels
leiden und die am wenigsten einen
beitrag dazu geleistet haben
jetzt nach der pandemie sagen viele wir
werden das nutzen als möglichkeit für 11
grüne nachhaltige erholung was hat das
bedeutet die
führungsleute sprechen building bank
besser
definieren irgendwelche fernen
klimaziele und vorzugeben dass sie
maßnahmen ergreifen aber die tatsache
dass wir in einer krise
sie sind aus der wir uns nicht raus
bauen oder investieren können das zeigt
wie kurzsichtig die leute an der macht
sind und solange die vorgeben dass wir
die klimakrise mittel jetzigen system
lösen können um so mehr
wertvolle zeit werden wir vergeuden aber
selbst wenn wir das ignorieren wenn wir
bedenken dass wir das geld investieren
das geld mit dem man jetzt eigentlich
building bugs better anstrebt das was
besseres nach der krise möchten erzählt
möchte dann sehen wir wie heuchlerisch
unsere politiker sind das was die als
grünen definieren ist nicht gründen nur
zwei prozent der regierungsausgaben sind
in die richtung grüne energien geflossen
und 20 21
wird das land sei mit dem zweithöchsten
emissionsanstieg
jemals und die globalen emissionen
werden um 16 prozent ansteigen bis zum
jahr 20 30 im vergleich zum jahr 2010
jahr das habt ihr richtig gehört das
heißt immer wieder zeigten die
politiker welches ihre richtigen
interessen sind und diejenigen die an
der macht sind und es ist nicht
überzeichnet wäre ich sage das system
anscheinend wirklich scheißegal ist wie
es uns geht und das können wir nicht
mehr den machthabern überlassen dass die
sich dieser sache alleine annehmen
[Applaus]
ja wir müssen uns abstimmen ja ihr müsst
alle zur wahl gehen aber bedenkt wie mit
es dass das nicht ausreicht wir müssen
weiter auf die straße gehen wir müssen
unsere führungspolitiker
ansprechen und fordern wirklich klima
aktionen zu ergreifen es gibt keinen weg
zurück aber es gibt die möglichkeit eine
wende zu erzielen die menschen sind
bereit für den wandel wir wollen wandeln
wir fordern wandel und wir stellen den
wandel da wir sind der wandel
ganz herzlichen dank dankeschön
[Applaus]
von greta tun werk in berlin
und david sind wir wieder hier zurück im
studio sie hat ihre thesen noch einmal
wiederholt sie hat davon gesprochen dass
keine politische partei genug tut um dem
klimawandel zu begegnen sie hat noch mal
deutschland benannt als viert größten
co2 emittenten einer der größten
klimasünder in der geschichte wie sie
sagt und sie hat gesagt es ist den
politikern ich zitiere scheiß egal wie
es den jungen leuten geht und das muss
sich ändern ihr müsst wählen gehen hat
sie gesagt aber ihr müsst auch weiter
auf die straße gehen und für unsere
ziele kämpfen für die ziele von friday
is for future ich möchte wieder
professor harald lesch zurück in die
runde holen und frau professor kittel
vom ifo institut in münchen
frau professor titel wie hat das auf sie
gewirkt ist dass die wiederholung von
dem was wir schon kennen aber mit noch
mehr rage und furor weil man sieht in
deutschland geht es um eine wahl es geht
darum zu wählen und es geht darum
politiker aufzurütteln und
wahlversprechen und themen auch in
inhalte und konkrete politik umzusetzen
also überrascht es mich jetzt nicht dass
es passt schon zu dem was weiter auf
lucio ja immer auch vertreten hat und im
prinzip die feststellung dass wir mit
den aktuellen programm nicht mal unsere
ziele einheiten unsere ziele führen
nicht zu 1,5 grad
das ist denke ich jetzt auch nichts
neues aber das wichtige ist eben dass
das tatsächlich dann auch in den
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht untergeht
man sieht moment deutlich man umfragen
sich anschaut klima ist zumindest bei
den umfragen die ich kenne wichtiger als
corona inzwischen wieder aber das spielt
sich eben bisher nicht wirklich im
langfristigen fundamentalen maßnahmen
wie da gibt es hier mal ein
subventionsprogramm und da mal wieder
ein aufschlag aber brauchen halt
wirklich einen grundlegenden wandel und
der ist nicht in zwei oder vier jahren
zu schaffen das heißt er muss in der
nächsten legislaturperiode müssen ganz
viele dinge angestoßen werden mit wir
überhaupt eine chance haben die ziele
die uns jetzt das klimaschutzgesetz
vorgibt aufdruck das verfassungsgericht
werde überhaupt erreichen an der stelle
fordere ich gerne noch mal dazu auf oder
am muntere und ermutige dazu ihre und
eure fragen zu stellen die ich dann sehr
gerne gleich an greta thunberg
weitergebe wenn sie bei uns hier im
interview ist wie immer in die
kommentare oder an zdf
heute.de
zdf.de herr professor lesch bei allem
was sich in richtung deutschland richtet
anforderungen kommt sehr reflexartig bei
vielen die antwort ja moment wir mögen
vielleicht der fit größte co2 emittent
sein aber da sind ja noch china und da
ist ja noch russland und in den was
können wir denn schon ausrichten wenn
wir hier so viel klimaschutz machen was
antworten sie da
die standard antwort ist natürlich
natürlich können wir viel ausrichten
deutschland ist über lange zeit
exportweltmeister gewesen hat
hervorragende wirtschaftliche kontakte
in die ganze welt verdient geld damit
eben waren und technologien zu
exportieren mit anderen worten wenn wir
endlich mal anfangen würden tatsächlich
auch technologien im bereich der
erneuerbaren so zu exportieren dass wir
damit anderen ländern die fehler
ersparen die wir gemacht haben dann wäre
natürlich viel gewonnen wir sind für
viel mehr emissionen verantwortlich als
nur die berühmten zwei prozent insgesamt
hat europa ja viele dreckige also co2
emittieren industrien irgendwohin
outgesourced wird es ja genannt das
heißt die umweltschäden entstehen wo
anders aber nicht mehr in europa bei uns
ist die luft sauber geworden bei uns das
wasser sauber geworden und und und und
trotzdem stehen wir natürlich als
diejenigen da die ganz massiv für diese
emissionen verantwortlich sind und ich
kann nur sagen in der rede von kreta
thunberg ist endlich mal wieder das wort
notfall gefahr das ist nämlich etwas
ganz anderes als eine krise die sich
irgendwie händel lässt wir müssen uns
alle mal daran erinnern was passiert
eigentlich wenn dann notfall für uns ist
oder also wenn einer der lieben von uns
eine eine dem an die wir kennen oder wie
auch immer wir sind nur notfalls
situationen dann spielen auf einmal die
ganzen terminpläne die wir gehabt haben
unser termin geländer spielt keine rolle
mehr sondern es muss jetzt geholfen
werden und das klingt natürlich nach
alarmismus aber das muss es inzwischen
auch denn die auswirkungen des
klimawandels auf unsere
lebensbedingungen sind so dramatisch
dass man fast gar nicht mehr anders kann
als tatsächlich mindestens mal ein mal
in der woche regelmäßig daran zu
erinnern wie katastrophal die situation
ist und es ist in der tat die frage wie
karin mittel das ja eben auch gesagt hat
wie wir das tatsächlich umsetzen wollen
es ist eine große eine riesengroße
aufgabe und es ist höchst bedauerlich
dass wir so viele jahre haben ja wir
haben sie verdoppelt vernich weil wir
unter anderem auch gerade in der politik
über jahrzehnte er auf die ihnen gehört
haben moment mal das ist ja gar nicht so
klar mit dem klimawandel und ob wir
daran schuld sind das ja auch gar nicht
so klar wir haben uns über 40 jahre lang
von leuten erzählen lassen es gebe
überhaupt keinen klimawandel und wenn es
ihn gibt haben wir nichts damit zu tun
und die scherben die liegen heute vor
uns
verlässt mit der bitte um eine ganz
kurze antwort in diesem blog weil ich
sehe dass brad hat 100 gerade schon
verkabelt wird und fast fertig ist für
das interview danach reden wir weiter
aber ich möchte sie dann ungern in
berlin dort draußen warten lassen
gestern haben wir bei der schlussrunde
erlebt dass sich die kandidatinnen und
kandidaten versucht haben zu überbieten
was sie selber für den gegen den
klimawandel tun frau berg fährt bus herr
söder ist weniger fleisch herr laschet
auch wie wichtig ist denn tatsächlich
der persönliche verzicht
der ist wichtig aber es muss vor allen
dingen ordnungsrahmen dasein in dem
dieser persönliche verzichten auch
tatsächlich eben positive wirkungen
zeigt es nutzt nichts wenn wir alle
sozusagen unser beitrag leisten ausgabe
aber das ganze eben nicht in den
richtigen unter den richtigen
rahmenbedingungen die insgesamt den
ausbau von erneuerbaren aber hin zu
einer mehr nachhaltigen lebensweise
führt dass das allerwichtigste dass
diese kombination von individuellen und
kollektiven zusammengeht das ist ja auch
eine last für viele junge leute die
gerade denken ich muss die welt retten
und ich muss jetzt öfter mit dem fahrrad
fahren das ist ja auch ein dilemma
na klar war klar ich meine und wenn sie
mit dem fahrrad fahren und nehmen sich
dann irgendwelche groß boliden sehen die
so genannten premium limousinen die da
also mit 300 ps von
an ihnen vorbei rauschen dann fühlen sie
sich schon ein bisschen auf deutsch
gesagt verharscht also wie kann denn das
sein und das ist in der tat auch ein
punkt über dem man immer und immer
wieder reden muss wie können wir zum
beispiel die urban siedlungsräume so vom
verkehr befreien das eben fahrradfahren
die art und weise ist wie die die man
bevorzugen sollte oder öffentlichen
nahverkehr vor allen dingen ganz stark
zu machen um damit wir endlich auch
führen mit dieser individuellen
mobilität die aber auf der anderen seite
für deutschland ja ein richtiges
geschäftsmodell ist das darf man nicht
unterschätzen
was heißt hier muss was passieren was
muss veränderung passieren ja es muss
passt sie was passieren sagt harald
lesch und das sagt auch greta tonwerk
die uns gerade schon zuwinkt und hören
kann wie ich sehe da ist sie in berlin
ich kann sie schon gut hören ich hoffe
sie kann uns auch gut hören wir können
sie auch schon sehen das bild wird noch
ein berichtet ich habe das gefühl sie
kann uns noch nicht wirklich hören
hallo hier ist christian sternberg aus
mainz dreht da können sie mich hören
[Applaus]
dass nämlich als ein jahr sie kann mich
hören ich hoffe dass ich versuche es
noch einmal hallo geräte aus
hallo belegten thunberg hier ist das
studio in mainz können sie mich hören
[Musik]
also liebe regie ich würde sagen wir
versuchen das noch mal neu und nutzen
die chance um die frage nach der
individuellen verantwortung noch mal mit
frau professor kittel zu gesprächen wie
sehen sie das wie groß ist die last des
einzelnen die getragen werden muss
es ist eine verdammt schwierige frage
also dass ich auch gerade als ich habe
zugehört recht zugehört habe ich denke
jeder kann was tun da sollten wir uns
auch gar nicht erst was vormachen wir
können unsere lebensweise ändern wir
können unseren ernährungsweise ändern
das bringt alles was aber es wird
natürlich nicht das gesamte problem
beseitigen das heißt wir brauchen eine
mischung aus allem und ich glaube harald
lesch abbringen gesagt wir haben so die
sind negative geschichte über den
klimaschutz ich habe er das gefühl wir
haben sehr lange eine sehr positive
geschichte gehabt wir setzen ganz tolle
ziele und wir machen das alles und es
wird uns überhaupt nichts kosten und ist
wird schon etwas kosten müssen die texte
technologien ändern wir müssen im
prinzip auf andere technologien auch
langfristig komplett umsteigen und das
wird zumindest während der umstellung
schon teurer werden oder sollten uns
ehrlich machen aber nicht alles ist
verzicht umstieg auf dem fahrrad muss
kein verzicht seien 41 das fleisch muss
nicht als verzicht wahrgenommen werden
das kommt leicht frivol mann
argumentierte das ist ja auch oft eine
große stadt land problematik es gibt
viele die haben sagen ich kann nicht mit
dem fahrrad fahren es gibt bei mir kein
üblich kommen sonst gar nicht zur arbeit
ja das ist auch eine der großen
schwierigkeiten natürlich wenn wir
wollen dass die leute die menschen einen
anderen lebenswandel in vielen bereichen
für müssen wir alternativen auch zur
verfügung stellen bzw diese eben
entwickeln und gerade auf dem land ist
natürlich sowohl der öffentliche
personennahverkehr als auch teilweise
wenn sie anderer haushalte sind eben die
umstellung auf elektromobilität nicht so
einfach aber es gibt natürlich auch
konzepte und die müssen weiterentwickelt
werden wir zum beispiel call on demand
also dass man ein bus ruft wenn man ihn
braucht damit er nicht immer leer hin
und her pendelt es gibt vieles was man
machen kann was aber jetzt da darf
natürlich schon recht häufig noch nicht
wirklich konsequent verfolgt wurde aber
ohne alternative können nicht ausweichen
dann versuche ich es nochmal nach berlin
es tut mir leid dass wir hier zwischen
münchen berlin und mainz so hin und her
springen aber das dürfte kein problem
sein greta triberg in berlin können sie
mich jetzt hören
[Applaus]
da ich höre sie uns großartig hallo
peter vielen dank dass sie bei uns in
der sendung sind das ist eine besondere
sendung wir haben immer viele zuschauer
und user kommentare und userin
kommentare deshalb nicht wundern wenn
ich jetzt einige fragen stelle die ich
quasi nur stellvertretend weitergebe und
gleich die erste kommt von einem user
namens matten um 1 der fragt wie blicken
sie frau thunberg auf die wahl in
deutschland
jedem war er jedoch internet ist immer
wichtig aber diese könnte besonders
wichtig sein dass deutschland ein so
wichtiges land ist und auch so viele
co2-emissionen schon immer in die luft
emittiert hat deswegen wird diese wahl
ist eine ganz wichtige rolle spielen
oder auch wichtige folgen haben für die
zukünftigen generationen
und auch für diese generation ist aber
nicht die einzige wichtige wahl wir
müssen auch danach weiter machen und nur
zur wahl zu gehen reicht nicht denn wir
müssen aktivistinnen und aktivisten
seien und mehr fordern denn das was die
politischen parteien fordern reicht
einfach nicht aus um das pariser
abkommen zu erzielen und zu erreichen
was darin gefordert ist nun sehen wir
hier gerade in deutschland geht bei
verschiedenen parteien gehen die ideen
sehr auseinander die grünen zum beispiel
sagen wir müssen eher auf verbote setzen
denn dann erst wird neuer erfindergeist
geweckt und die fdp zum beispiel sagt
nein verbote bringen gar nichts wir
haben so viel innovation in deutschland
wir müssen die eher fördern und dazu
gibt es auch eine frage eines users
namens ende war der fragt über youtube
inwiefern sollte man beim klimaschutz
auf innovation statt auf
reglementierungen setzen um das pariser
klimaschutz abkommen einzuhalten
[Musik]
natürlich kommt das jeweils auf die
situation an einer bestimmten situation
kann auch die innovation sehr sehr
wichtig sein aber ich finde es schon
komisch dass wir immer noch über die
klimakrise
diskutieren und uns fragen ob die unser
die innovation alleine gelöst werden
kann also um die klimakrise zu lösen
müssen wir sie als echte krise
anerkennung und das ist sie ja und man
kann nicht einfach nur auf seiner ebene
darüber sprechen unter den
unterschiedlichen politischen fragen das
die sich da unterschiedliche konzepte
einfach zu werfen und nur über
innovation sprechen das geht nicht
gestern abend haben wir hier in einer
sendung auch im zdf erlebt dass viele
der drei kanzlerkandidaten und die
kanzlerkandidatin erklärt haben was sie
persönlich gegen den klimawandel machen
also ob sie mit dem bus fahren oder
autofahren oder fleisch essen wie
relevant ist das aus ihrer sicht ob der
nächste deutsche kanzler oder die
nächste deutsche kanzlerin wenig fleisch
isst oder viel fleisch oder gar kein
fleisch
natürlich können solch kleine dinge
symbolisch sein aber insgesamt müssen
wir aufhören uns auf diese einzelnen
individuellen maßnahmen zu konzentrieren
und uns auf große maßnahmen
konzentrieren wenn jemand kanzler von
deutschland ist dann ist es wichtiger
was er nationale und internationale der
politik tut stadt das was er jeden tag
in seinem persönlichen leben tut zu
bedanken und das was der kanzler oder
die kanzlerin dann tut das bewegt viele
in deutschland auch unter dem aspekt der
sozialen frage ein user namens ansgar 72
fragt wie finden sie es dass aufgrund
des klimaschutzes wie er sagt alles
verteuert wird was denken sie darüber
dass sich sozial schwächere das so nicht
leisten können
think its competitors ist also wenn das
stimmt nicht klimagerechtigkeit bedeutet
ja gerechtigkeit und natürlich
klimagerechtigkeit nicht haben ohne
soziale gerechtigkeit zu haben das ist
ein fairer und gerechter übergang der
sfd erforderlich deswegen brauchen wir
klima aktionen die für alle
möglich sind glauben sie eine klima
nicola nationen
die gleichzeitig soziale ungerechtigkeit
fördern das wären nicht die richtigen
klimamaßnahmen also eine große
herausforderung an die neue an die neue
bundesregierung
ob das pariser klimaschutzabkommen
überhaupt erreicht werden kann und
welche maßnahmen die regierung dann
ergreift das interessiert auch viele
userinnen und user benjamin rupp fragt
ist das pariser klimaabkommen überhaupt
noch ausreichend
[Musik]
man könnte jetzt natürlich hier nokia
kommentieren ob das aber hermann
hinreicht aber wir haben nun mal das
pariser klimaabkommen und das steht drin
dass die erderwärmung auf jeden fall bei
15 uhr landen dürfen und nicht bei zwei
das ist natürlich nicht rechts
und das ist natürlich ein defizit wenn
es
ambitioniertes leben gehört dann wären
sowohl ich als auch viele andere klima
aktivistinnen und aktivisten mehr als
froh aber das ist das was wir im moment
mehr haben wir im moment nicht edu sah
fragt ganz praktisch über youtube wie
überzeuge ich als junge erwachsene meine
eltern und die ältere generation denn
der also den eltern und der älteren
generation den ernst der lage zu
erklären
[Musik]
gute frage
ich kenne viele junge leute die sich
dieselbe frage stellen und ich war auch
einmal in der lage ich habe auch ganz
klein angefangen ich habe auch erst
einmal meinen eltern und großeltern
erklärt wie wichtig es ist das licht
immer auszumachen keine energie zu
vergeuden etz schritt ist zugleich
das beste was man machen kann ist den
eltern wirklich zu erklären dass sie den
wissenschaftlern doch zu hören sollen ob
es jetzt bücher sind oder grafische
darstellungen oder filme oder welches
material man auch immer zu rate zieht um
ihnen das wirklich immer wieder vor zu
führen um sie immer wieder daran zu
erinnern dass hab ich so gemacht und es
hat ja auch funktioniert
es gibt ja auch viele gerade junge leute
die haben richtig angst die haben angst
vor der zukunft und in diese richtung
geht eine frage von einem user namens i
punkt g punkt was würdest du was würden
sie denjenigen sagen die die klimakrise
als aussichtslos betrachten und davon
ausgehen dass sich eh nicht genug
schnell etwas ändern
[Musik]
da habe ich laut hintergrund
des werks und ich weiß dass viele leute
manchmal recht zweifel sind die sagen
der kleine hase kann man eh nicht sehen
das ist alles aussichtslos aber schaut
euch doch mal was in bewegung erreicht
hat natürlich sind wir noch sehr weit
entfernt davon übrig zu haben millionen
von euro basiert und das ist etwas was
wir was machen können wäre keine klima
aktivistinnen und aktivisten denn wir
nicht davon überzeugt werden dass wir
die dinge nicht auch verändern können
und je mehr leute sich uns anschließen
desto besser und dann werden die leute
auch davon überzeugt werden dass man
gemeinsam was erreichen kann und ich bin
so inspiriert und hoffnungsfroh dann
dieser bewegung dass ich sicher bin dass
wir die dinge ändern können wenn ich mit
den leuten spreche da bin ich wirklich
inspiriert dich so sehen dass es leute
gibt die große veränderung erzielen
möchten
die wissen es gibt die klimakrise und
möchten die sache die situation ändern
manche fallen in depression und möchten
deswegen weil es aussichtslos erscheint
gar nichts machen aber wenn man sich
anschaut welche
auswirkungen die klimakrise hat dann
kann man auch sagen ich möchte maßnahmen
ergreifen auf die straße gehen und das
alles ändern
eine letzte persönliche frage hätte ich
noch von thomas b der fragt hinter
fragst du deinen eigenen also
hinterfragen sie ihren eigenen
standpunkt regelmäßig
[Musik]
wie soll ich den eltern fragen na ja es
tut gut sich auch immer mal die in die
schuhe des anderen zu stellen und in die
schuhe derjenigen zu stellen die anderer
meinung sind und zu überlegen was es von
der anderen seite könnte vielleicht ein
argument sein was ich noch nicht gesehen
habe was an meiner sicht könnte
vielleicht irgendwie doch anders sein
als ich es bisher gedacht habe oder sind
sie felsenfest von dem überzeugt jeden
tag in jedem standpunkt den sie
vertreten
natürlich nicht ich bin immer sehr offen
für andere standpunkte
als ich von der klimakrise gehört habe
da war ich noch ganz jung und da habe
ich das erste mal geleugnet da habe ich
den leuten auch nicht geglaubt und ich
glaube glaubte gar nicht dass das alles
passiert und dann habe ich ganz viel
gelesen und dann habe ich mit ganz
vielen fachleuten gesprochen und dann
kam ich
in die situation dass ich mir das urteil
gebildet habe dass die klimakrise eine
realität ist natürlich bin ich nicht von
allem überzeugt ob man muss immer räumen
seien ich habe mit so vielen leuten
gesprochen die
unterschiedlichste meinungen haben und
bin aber zu der überzeugung gelangt dass
das der richtige weg ist
vielen dank kreta thonberg für das
interview und für die beantwortung der
vielen vielen usern fragen vielen dank
nach berlin dankeschön
und damit sind wir wieder über das
studio in mainz in münchen bei harald
lesch und frau professor karin titel
frau titel man hat ja nicht das gefühl
dass diese bewegungen am ende ist man
hat das gefühl sie ist immer noch sehr
am anfang die argumente die
bedrohungslage das ist alles noch so wie
zu beginn
des ersten der ersten klima streiks und
des beginns der aktion von greta
thunberg aber offensichtlich ist es eine
bewegung die gerade erst dabei ist zu
sehen wie viel einfluss sie auch auf die
politik nehmen kann oder
ja ich denke auch nicht dass das in
kürzerer zeit zu ende gehen wird oder zu
ende gehen sollte was wir gesehen haben
in den letzten jahren auch sei der
future gekommen sind ist eine sehr
starke anpassung der ziele
in deutschland auf europäischer ebene es
geht vielleicht nicht so weit wie frei
die surf users ist gerne möchte aber es
ist auf jeden fall einen ganzen schritt
weiter als noch vor ein paar jahren
waren aber den punkt den wir jetzt
wirklich schaffen müssen ist wegzukommen
von die ziele möchten wir haben und wir
brauchen eine transformation das wissen
wir wir müssen jetzt langsam dahin
kommen was machen wird und da ist immer
noch die große lücke also insofern hat
sich reif user auf jeden fall bemerkbar
gemacht in wo wollen wir hin mehr als
100 länder heutzutage wollen
klimaneutralität bis um 2050 herum aber
bei den wenigsten findet man weiß nie ob
es überhaupt eins gibt wenn man
tatsächlich den konkreten weg dahin
er löscht sie als
wissenschaftsjournalist müssten noch
eigentlich frustriert sein dass die welt
so lange warten musste bis ein kleines
mädchen aus schweden kam und gesagt hat
so leute jetzt reicht es wir sehen ja
schon seit jahrzehnten ist das thema da
aber erst jetzt nimmt es richtig auf
fahrern an fahrt auf wie hoffnungsvoll
sind sie denn dass sich tatsächlich
jetzt auch was tut dass die politik das
auch die wirtschaft das erkennt
also ich bin ja der
wissenschaftsjournalist ich bin ihrer
wissenschaftler und für mich ist es erst
mal wie ich das für ihn schon mal gesagt
habe eine wichtiges zeichen dass
aufgefordert wird und zwar offenbar
wirksam aufgefordert wird follows
science also hört auf die die
wissenschaft betragen und das hätte man
schon viel früher machen sollen und zwar
ziemlich klar und ziemlich eindeutig ich
habe mich eben bei dem interview mit
fortune berg ein bisschen gewundert
darüber dass man ernsthaft fragen kann
hinterfragen sie ihre positionen denn
wir reden hier ja nicht über meinungen
beim thema waren wir reden über
tatsachen und es gibt einen schönen satz
jeder hat das recht auf eine eigene
meinung aber nicht auf eigene tatsachen
das heißt man muss hier schon mal gibb
und klar sagen dass natürlich die
tatsachen so eindeutig sind inzwischen
dass keine vernünftige politische kraft
mehr darum herum kommt dass die nächsten
100 jahre davon geprägt sein werden wie
gehen wir mit dem klimaschutz und das
ist die aufgabe schlechthin und
verzweiflung ist da eigentlich gar keine
option sondern das ist ein bisschen eher
so wie sisyphos der eben diese kugel da
immer hoch gerollt hat wir müssen von
allen seiten in der wissenschaft gerade
dann wenn die wenn die junge jüngere
generationen dazu aufruft follows 1 muss
die wissenschaft auch da sein muss auch
klar formulieren was ist der fall und
was muss geschehen damit bei den
handlungsoptionen dann auch ganz klar
wird wo es eigentlich hingehen muss und
dann müssen wir sehen wie kriegen wir
diese option umgesetzt was passiert in
der wirklichkeit ich meine wie kann das
eben gesagt hat wir werden jetzt müssen
wir die entsprechenden stellschrauben so
drehen dass wenigstens mal ein
richtungswechsel passiert also die zeit
der diagnosen ist vorbei jetzt geht es
darum welche therapien werden eingesetzt
und weil es gibt therapien die sind
schmerzhaft uns gibt therapien die sind
zunächst einmal weniger schmerzhaft wir
werden uns auf jeden fall darauf
einstellen müssen dass hier ganz
gewaltige veränderung stattfinden und
ganz ehrlich gesagt ich glaube gar nicht
dass die politik keine große wahl hat
sie kann gar nicht mehr um das klima
thema herum gehen sie muss sich
irgendwie ziemlich
deutlich und auch vor allen dingen
richtungs verändern damit beschäftigen
ansonsten wird uns die die die umwelt
mit ihren entsprechenden wirkungen
einfach ziemlich deutlich zu verstehen
gegeben dass das lebensbedingungen sind
die für uns katastrophal sein werde
ich will den user gar nicht in schutz
nehmen aber ich glaube ich habe ihn so
verstanden dass er nicht grundsätzlich
sie fragt ob sie hinterfragt dass das
den klimawandel gibt und dass etwas
dagegen getan werden muss aber was man
dagegen tun muss das ist natürlich auch
was was sich immer weiterentwickelt und
mit neueren erkenntnissen wird man auch
feststellen der und der co2 ausstoß wird
immer noch zu viel sein dass und das
gras hier wird immer noch zu wenig sein
also das ist ja was worüber sich die
wissenschaft sehr wohl auseinander
setzen kann und muss und das ist
vielleicht auch tatsächlich der
konstruktive nächste schritt also wenn
wir alle verstanden haben dass sich
etwas tun muss dann können wir
konstruktiv darüber reden wie wir das
machen und wie wir den co2 bepreisung
machen zum beispiel und da hab ich das
gefühl steht deutschland auch gerade mit
hinblick auf die bundestagswahl erst
ganz am anfang aber
das geld das ist ja eine ganz andere
frage also die frage die die haltung zum
klimawandel ist eine ganz andere frage
als die frage der der handlungen die
dann tatsächlich eher von menschen
durchgeführt werden der klimawandel ist
eine reaktion der natur darauf dass wir
mehr treibhausgase eingetragen haben und
es einfach immer wärmer wird es wird
einfach immer wärmer und dadurch
reagieren sämtliche natürlichen bereiche
genau so wie man es erwarten würde das
eis wird weniger das wasser wird saurer
und so weiter und so weiter und auf der
anderen seite steht eben das was wir in
der sogenannten an troposphäre also in
der sphäre des menschen tun können wir
können uns organisieren wir können
versuchen
handlungsoptionen dann zu identifizieren
und sie dann einzusetzen aber das
natürlich auch keine frage für eine
klima aktivistin soll es eine frage an
diejenigen die jetzt verantwortung
tragen in den verschiedenen ländern
deswegen kann ich bin ich bin ich
einfach ich war einfach ein bisschen
irritiert
man dieser jungen frau seine frage
stellt die man eigentlich einem
staatsmann oder einer premierministerin
stellen sollte aber doch nicht
denjenigen die wirklich verstanden haben
der klimawandel ist eine so
katastrophale herausforderung da muss
was getan werden und insofern ist jetzt
sozusagen die eine klima aktivisten zu
befragen wie wie wie hinter fragst du
deine deine position kann ich kann ich
da nicht nachvollziehen sondern geht es
darum harte politische entscheidungen
und klare politische entscheidung und da
muss man an diejenigen rangehen und die
befragen die tatsächlich diese
entscheidungen treffen und nicht
diejenigen die jetzt auf die straße
gehen und endlich mal ziemlich deutlich
zur stimme geben so geht es nicht weiter
das war mein punkt werden wobei sie ja
schon erfahrung damit hat fragen zu
beantworten die eigentlich die
staatsmänner dieser welt beantworten
sollten und auch inzwischen leuten wie
angela merkel oder herrn kusch zum
beispiel erklärt was zu tun wäre also
von daher fühlt sie sich wahrscheinlich
in dieser rolle nicht nicht neu frau
professor titel ich möchte gerne noch
mal einen blick auf die weltweite
verantwortung
werfen wenn wir uns angucken das bmw zum
beispiel beschlossen hat in deutschland
keine verbrennung mehr zu produzieren
aber die produktion verlagert die
fertigung von diesel und benzinmotoren
aus dem münchner stammwerk zum beispiel
nach großbritannien oder nach österreich
da fragt man sich das sieht super aus
für die deutschen das bringt dem klima
weltweit aber gar nichts
wir fahren die autos wieder zurück
importiert werden nach deutschland aber
ich glaube das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkte implizit damit schwingt das hatte
vorhin halt leicht auch erwähnt über
outsourcing also eine gefahr gibt es
einfach wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel
adhoc unsere co2 180 euro anheben würden
wir machen das was die eu momentan plant
auch um die eu wirtschaft zu schützen
dann würde man eine mensa abwanderung
sind von industrien andere länder und
dort dann die emission das heißt also es
ist die klimakrise ist real aber müssen
uns auch durchaus klug überlegen wie wir
diese instrumente mit denen wir dagegen
vorgehen auch gestalten in meiner
abwanderung nach österreich bringen
insofern relativ wenig und es auch eu
ist und wer doch relativ ihn auch auf eu
ebene geregelt haben das ist dann
irgendwann natürlich auch vielleicht
auch die angst vor der der
öffentliche meinung in deutschland
möglicherweise auch forderungen die hier
kriege die ich woanders nicht bekomme
das sind alles aspekte die wir mit
reinspielen aber das ist im prinzip ist
weist darauf hin nicht alles was erstmal
super aussieht ist tatsächlich auch
effektiv oder ist auch wirklich sehr gut
da muss man eben schon genau hingucken
insofern lohnt sich dann auch über was
mache ich eigentlich detailliert dazu
diskutieren und nicht auf dem wir müssen
was machen im niveau zu verbleiben dann
sind wir gespannt auf das was die
parteien dann nach der bundestagswahl
machen mich irritiert das übrigens total
frau professor titel wenn sie dann nach
rechts gucken dann denke ich immer sie
gucken zu herrn lesch weil das hier auf
moniz vor so aussieht aber der ist ja
gar nicht bei ihnen der raum aber sehen
aber
das sind so aus als wären sie im
gespräch und ich freue mich dass sie
miteinander auch im gespräch bleiben
werden ob bei uns in der sendung oder in
anderen sendungen oder in münchen ganz
direkt herr professor lesch einen hätte
ich noch hinten raus und zwar weil wir
ja kurz vor der bundestagswahl sinn
fragt der user look pro resch vor
kanzler also das ist in dem fall eine
fördere und eine vordere
also sie haben hier fans ist das eine
option für sie half
[Gelächter]
alles klar dann sage ich vielen dank für
die rege beteiligung vielen dank nach
münchen vielen dank für die auf konter
noch eine begründung hinterher liegt
ihnen da noch eine begründung auf der
zunge oder bleibt einfach beim nein
ich wollte eigentlich wollte eigentlich
nur karin noch mal grüßen und freue mich
wenn wir uns demnächst wieder sehen
werden zumindest der einzige kanzler der
in schnell fragerunden tatsächlich nur
mit einem satz antwortet oder mit mord
oder kanzlerkandidat das unterschreibe
ich sie schon mal von denen die im
moment kandidieren vielen dank herr
professor lesch vielen dank frau
professor kittel und vielen dank für sie
zu hause oder wo auch immer fürs
mitmachen und mit kommentieren und
fragen bis zum nächsten mal tschüss